hello everyone and welcome to some
incredible action-packed games from the
US Chess Championship we already
mentioned in the previous video that
after four rounds have been played the
leader is Fabiano corana who also won
last year's us Chess Championship so uh
you know he is very strong obviously and
uh not to be surprised as he is the
former World chest Championship
Contender he faced Magnus Carlson he is
always a part of the candidates
tournament so he is the top seat here
and he is the one uh that everyone wants
to to beat in here
uh Dar has a very good chance he has
black pieces but uh he uh played an
incredible incredible game here now uh
what this game is about is basically uh
Fabby uh Fabby employs the Magnus uh
technique he he plays nothing
spectacular like he plays a line that
doesn't give him any advantage but that
can be played indefinitely and here as
Fab is the stronger player you can see
that there's quite a bit of a a rating
difference 2786 to 2620 uh fabbi is
confident that he will be able to take a
full point but that's a lot easier said
than done as you'll see in this game so
uh let's check it out Fabby plays Pawn
to E4 and we have Pawn to E5 Knight F3
Knight to C6 and Bishop to C4 already a
pleasant surprise at least for me not
going for the R Lopez going for the
Italian game Knight to F6 the two kns
defense and D3 the modern Bishop's
opening with Bishop to C5 uh castles and
pawn to D6 so these are all very
standard moves that you see pretty much
in every other
uh Bishop to C4 game we have Pawn to H6
Knight B to D2 and now castles we have
Pawn to H3 uh and now Pawn to A5 now
it's a uh not a lot of games have been
played here but the position has been
reached by some very very strong players
for example karakin had it against anaa
haded against saturan maulu haded
against petan and and the list goes on
with Rook to E1 Bishop to E6 and now
Pawn to B3 now you could take the bishop
here but white will very gladly capture
with the B Pawn have a very strong grip
on the D5 Square also have some D4 ideas
in the future semi open B file for The
Rook so this is uh not what black should
be going for so Rook to E8 nicely
continuing development Bishop to B5 now
pinning the Knight and Bishop back to D7
and now there are some games where
Bishop to B2 was played but here fa goes
Knight to F1 preparing Knight to E3 then
to F5 and it is now as of move 13 that
we have a completely new game so okay
Knight the B8 offering a trade of
Bishops Fabby goes for it Bishop
captures Knight captures and now Knight
to E3 and like we said this Knight is
now coming to F5 and um well uh Dar
already played Pawn to H6 and you really
don't want to play Pawn to G6 as well
that would be weakening the king side a
bit too much so he decides to give up
the bishop Bishop captures on E3 Bishop
captures and now Pawn to D5 uh if you
can play this of course it's very good
for you and you should always play it e
captures on D5 Knight captures and now
Bishop back to D2 not allowing the trade
of course Bishop for Knight but also
just guarding the C3 Pawn uh Pawn to C5
stop any stopping any expansions that
Faby might try Queen to C2 and now Queen
to C7 so white has zero Advantage here
there is nothing um that that white can
say Okay I I maybe didn't go for any
main lines but I have this no this is
playable for both sides and it's a very
nice position for both Rook e to
probably prepares to double up on the E
file go after the5 pawn and of course
darush prepares as well Rook E6 Rook a
to E1 and Rook a to E8 and now Fabby
plays Queen to B1 uh with some ideas of
maybe advancing the pawn to B4 in the
future we have Knight six to F6 Knight 7
to F6 and now comes Knight to H4 now
Fabby wants to bring the other Knight to
F5 the problem with B4 right away as I'm
sure you guys want to play it is that uh
once everything gets traded off okay you
have to capture with the bishop but now
you lost control over the F4 square and
now something like Knight to four and
black is already very strong attacking
The Rook uh putting pressure on the D3
Pawn the queen can come and help out
with the attack on the D3 Pawn uh you
didn't really gain anything so if anyone
is to be preferred here it is definitely
black so here Knight to H4 now Fabby
tries to bring the other Knight to the
F5 square and now bone to B6 uh we have
Knight to F5 so the first part of fa's
plan has been developed and you'd
probably expect um uh well what would
you expect here maybe it it's a really
strong Square for the Knight maybe just
kick it away right away so we could play
that and it it is definitely okay you
could capture let's say queen captures
white gets B4 in C captures C captures
and after a captures and Bishop captures
now you figure out what to do with the
queen let's say queen d8 the D3 Pawn is
a backwards pawn and you will have uh
problems with that pawn the queen will
be nicely centralized on D4 so you know
you you could play that definitely but
he goes for Queen to D7 now uh it's very
hard to beat someone who is satisfied
with a draw uh from from the starting
position but the DAR as I uh as we are
constantly reminded throughout the game
H did not come here to just fight for a
draw he wants to actually beat Fabby
with black so here we have Knight back
to H4 uh Knight to H5 and now Pawn to G3
taking away df4 Square from dar's
knights we have Knight six Knight H to
F6 and now Knight back to F3 Faby goes
after the E5 Pawn now it's attacked
three times and you probably expect
Queen to C7 or queen to D6 just
defending the pawn here but no he says
your H3 Pawn is undefended and I'm going
to take um that into consideration and
he plays Rook six to E7 it seems like a
uh sort of a waiting move not really
doing anything but he's just offering an
exchange of Pawns the E5 Pawn for the H3
Pawn uh to make something happen not to
keep the
position as it is and that's a good
mindset to have against strong players
you never want to have you know just
blockade the position against the a
strong player a stronger player will
always break through so it's always
better to be active we have Rook
captures on E5 Rook captures we have
Rook captures Rook captures Knight
captures on E5 and now Queen captures on
H3 so equal material uh but he did um
manage to grab the H3 pawn and if Faby
moves the Knight if Knight to G4 lands
could be very dangerous so here we have
Queen to D1 uh nicely guarding that G4
Square Queen back to F5 and now Queen to
E2 by Fabby we have Queen to E6 and now
Queen to E1 uh adding support uh
preparing to advance the pawn to B4 and
queen to F5 eyeing that undefended D3
Pawn King to G not undefended but if the
Knight moves it will be undefended king
to G2 and now Pawn to H5 now darish is
going after Fab's King we have Pawn to
C4 it's a nice move if it works but if
it doesn't you've created holes in your
position but the the thing is that the
uh if D for example plays Knight to B4
you don't really gain all that much by
trading here yes you double his pawns
but it's nothing spectacular there's no
way to actually create um some sort of a
pass Pawn or anything maybe if you were
able to take this into like a king and
Knight end game maybe you could like
sacrifice the Knight for the C5 pawn and
then start advancing but that's a long
long way off so C4 attacking the Knight
and just Knight back to C7 and now comes
Queen to E2 we have Knight to E6 the
Knight can now come to D4 excellent
square and Knight back to F3 defending
against this and here we have King to f8
uh if you if he felt um that he wanted
to play really sharp he could go for the
immediate G5 and you know no one would
would blame him but he wants to improve
the activity of his King first now it's
also a very instructive idea uh in your
own games when you will be playing you
it will be very hard to evaluate whether
to play King f8 or G5 first because um
okay once the position trades down let's
see Queens get traded off maybe it goes
into a bishop and Knight end game you
want your king as close to your B6 Pawn
as possible it's the base of the pawn
chain so it could be a very useful move
on the other hand it could also be just
a waste of a Tempo uh you know that is
the the fate of everyone who plays chess
you have to make decisions like this all
the time Bishop to C3 and now Pawn to G5
okay we have Knight to D2 by Faby uh
Pawn to H4 we have Knight to E4 now
adding more support here and Knight to
E4 is an excellent move because if the
position uh trades down like if you
trade Knight for Knight and if the
Queens get traded of the board then
Fabby is left with a knight Bishop
against the Knight and all of darius's
pawns are on dark squares Fabby has a
dark Square Bishop so those are all
potential targets so Faby plays E4
Knight E4 with great confidence as he
knows a trade of knights definitely
favors him due to the pawns being on
dark squares on the queen side so here
you could throw in a nice H captures and
G3 if you want it for example H captures
F captur then you trade Knight for
example D captures you move the Queen
the game continues however we have
Knight captures on e4 first first D
captures and queen to H7 keeping the
tension now Queen to G4 by Fabby H
captures and G3 F captures and now King
to E7 now as the position is getting
traded down it is better of course for
the king to be closer to the action as
possible uh Queen to F3 and now Queen to
G6 we have Queen to D3 Fabby preparing
to nicely centralize the queen with
Queen to D5 and queen to H5 with Bishop
to E5 now trying to get some action here
against the black king uh so King to E8
and now we have King to G1 uh we have
Queen to G4 and now Bishop to F6 now the
Knight is sort of paralyzed if you move
the Knight you're going to get
checkmated so darush has to go back with
the king king to f8 we have King to F2
and now uh King to G8 again you can't
move the Knight while the king is on f8
because this would again be Checkmate
the bishop covers E7 and the G7 uh uh
you know as well and here Fabby says uh
well if I can trade TR Queens here then
my Bishop should be better than Knight
as all of these pawns are on dark
squares and he goes for it Queen to D5
now the idea is of course Queen to A8
check followed by Queen to h8 check and
of course there's no way to stop this so
darush has to prepare for it and he
prepares with Queen to H5 okay Queen to
A8 with check King to H7 Queen to h8
with check King to G6 and now Queen
captures an H5 Faby goes for the queen
trade as his Bishop will now try to win
those pawns on dark squares King cap and
now Bishop to E5 he wants to play Bishop
to B8 and Bishop to A7 but as we always
say Knights are tricky bastards just
because the plan is on both sides of the
board doesn't mean that the Knight is
helpless or anything King to G4 and now
Bishop to B8 with Pawn to F5 and now
Fabby has to decide whether uh he has
time to go after the pawns right away or
does he have to react to this if he goes
Bishop to A7 right away then F4 H will
uh end up in in a pretty quick draw p
captures King captures Bishop captures
on B6 King captures on e4 and after
Bishop captures on A5 you will have
Knight to D4 you will go after the B3
Pawn it's impossible to defend Bishop C3
Knight captures and now after A5 you
will also just sacrifice the Knight and
um uh pick up the C4 pawn and that's
pretty much it once you capture the pawn
it's a draw uh if anything only black
can win this position of course fobby
would not lose this position but uh you
know it only black can win uh so after
F5 he has to react e captures on F5 King
captures on F5 and now we have Bishop to
A7 now Fabby finally grabs hold of those
dark Square pawns and now Knight to D4
going after the base of the pawn chain
Bishop captures on B6 and Knight
captures on B3 and you have this very
weird structure here where the bishop is
attacking both pawns and the Knight is
defending both pawns so uh the king's
can't really go Queens side to help out
with the action uh because each King has
to defend his own Pawn so what do we do
with this position of course objectively
it's a draw every position is
objectively a draw but um of course
Fabby will play it for as long as
possible King E3 G4 now grabbing more
space here gaining control over D F3
Square uh Bishop to C7 now comes uh a
very strong idea limiting the movement
of the black king so the Knight cannot
move if the Knight moves you will just
gobble up the A5 Pawn the pawns cannot
move so the only piece Dar has that can
move is the black king and now you are
taking away some squ from the black king
So King to E6 now comes King to E4 but
of course darish will not not allow
Fabby to advance anywhere Knight to D2
check King to D3 and Knight back to B3
but now uh of course if you go King to B
Bishop to B6 then uh dar's King is even
close enough to go King D7 King C8 King
to B7 and so on so fa goes Bishop to F4
and now comes King to F5 here
interestingly the only move for Dar is
Knight to D4 uh but he played King to F5
as you know many of us would but now
it's time to win the game for Fabby and
it's uh really really tricky why King to
F5 I mean it's a basically a Tempo game
one tempo wins it or loses it or draws
it uh feel free to pause the video and
try to find the only winning move for
Fabby while I give you a couple of
[Music]
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on being a
true Master of the end game and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Bishop to E3 it's like I said
it's a Tempo game and here we are just
taking away important squares from the
black king so the Knight cannot move uh
you will lose the pawn the pawns cannot
move only uh one that can move is the
king and you cannot move to G5 so of
course if you go backwards you uh allow
the the king to E4 so King to E5 now
comes Bishop to H6 and okay nothing
seems to change uh we have King to F5
still boxing in the white king not
allowing him anywhere but now Bishop to
to G7 and now the king can no longer
come to E5 and Fabby will win the E4
Square the problem with King to G6 going
after the bishop is that now you will
move the bishop to C3 again paralyzing
uh all all the pieces only the king can
move and after King F5 King E3 and now
after you you can't go here you have to
go here and then of course you win uh
the D4 square or you go up the board
King the E6 and then uh King to F4 and
you go after this Pawn so uh it does not
help you if you go after the bishop so
Knight to C1 check was played King to D2
now comes Knight back to B3 with check
King to E3 and now King to G6 now the
Knight has no more uh moves if you if
you just try to repeat with the KN
Knight C1 then comes Bishop to C3 after
the pawn and after Knight B3 King to D3
and after King to E6 you will again win
the E4 Square for your king so really uh
really an exhausting game to calculate
um you know when playing against Fabby
I'm sure as I've also uh you know have
been in time trouble in a classical game
just a few days ago so I can definitely
uh feel for darios here uh he played
King to G6 but now we basically
transpose into that position that we
already discussed F played Bishop back
to B2 uh King to F5 and now Bishop to C3
so just nicely triangulating winning um
the position over because you want this
position where it's Black's move you do
not want this position where it's
White's move and a bishop is a a
marvelous piece to Triangle it with you
can just you know move it along this
diagonal and choose squares um that uh
you know are good for you so you if you
go here then of course King to F4 darish
went King to G5 but now King to E4 Fabby
wins the E4 Square for his King King to
G6 now King to F4 King to H5 with have
King to F5 and now of course if you move
the king you lose the pawn so the Knight
has to move Knight C1 now Bishop
captures on A5 we have Knight to E2
going after the G3 Pawn but of course
Fabby just defends it we have Knight to
D4 with check King to E4 and now Knight
to C6 uh of course Fabby could just play
A5 but he doesn't rush it he plays
Bishop to D6 he wants to make it as
clean as possible Knights to A5 Bishop
captures and sorry not even that he
played King to D5 first uh King to G6
and now Bishop captures on C5 we have
King to F5 and now Bishop to B6 was
played and it was in this position on
move 80 that Dario resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
Fabby wins a a master class here in a in
a bishop versus knight end game and well
you you've seen how how much it takes
and how long you have to play in order
to prove your advantage and it wasn't
winning by default he could actually
defend this with Knight But It's Tricky
you have to find uh you know it will it
will not always be a move like okay I
play this and defend this it will be you
have to play this in order to Fork your
opponent in seven moves and then it's a
draw so uh that's why it's a bit easier
to play with the bishop uh but you know
if you if you know what you're doing of
course you can always hold it but um uh
you know they played a lot of moves
darish was also very long one time I
think he was down to his last minute
when the game ended so it was incredibly
difficult to make these decisions now
you either move the Knight if you go
here then we can even uh trap the Knight
because the bishop covers the d8 square
and if you go back of course just A5 and
that's it you will promote your Pawn to
a queen if the Knight sacrifices itself
for the pawn then this Pawn wins so it
is of course pointless to continue so
yeah Fabby wins a brilliant brilliant
game also he won a very nice game
against Jeffrey
shiong uh so uh uh that's why he is up
to three points and these are the
standings if you missed my previous
video uh on the US Chess Championship so
fa in first place with three out of four
followed by three people in the lead
Hans Neiman Sam shankland and abanu
Mishra uh then comes with two two two
out of four Dominguez Perez ler Wesley
saw Samuel seian and Leon Aran Andrew
Tang Jeffrey Shong and Dario SCH on one
and a half points and Ray Robson even
though he's an incredible player
currently on one out of four because he
just uh you know a fully packed field of
of incredibly strong players someone
always has to be in last place what are
you going to do uh so that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it um uh you know
hopefully you will be able to take
something from this in your own games
and it all came uh basically down to uh
this point where uh I believe no not not
even here like even
uh sorry like here when Fabby felt that
he could confidently play Knight to E4
because of all of these pawns are on
dark squares he has a dark Square Bop uh
it helps it just helps a lot sometimes
you will be able to hold a position with
tactics sometimes you know that it's a
it's much easier to play and fine moves
if you know that every trade favors you
like if you know you have a better Pawn
structure if you have a better end game
then uh you don't have to avoid trades
when you're when you have a worst
position uh that maybe objectively it's
a draw but you will have to avoid trades
it's much much uh more difficult to
calculate also something to you know
take into consideration uh so yeah once
again really hope you guys enjoyed it I
would like to wish a very happy Birthday
to Tommy and I would like to thank Mr
hoody Guy Peter marinov an anonymous
person and Roger Stone for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the US CH championship and whatever else
happens in the Chess World uh so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day